welcome
again to this press conference following
the eu us summit welcome to the press
joining us virtually and in this room
president michelle you have the floor
merci
beaucoup
it was a pleasure to host president
biden today
we share a long history with the united
states
we shaped much of the last century
and now it's time to shape this century
just after present balance election i
said the eu
and us should build a new founding pact
for a stronger alliance and a better
world
and we got to work immediately the
european council had a strategy debate
last december
on our transatlantic relationship we
hosted president biden at a virtual
meeting
in march and then our teams worked
and negotiated very intensively in the
last
weeks and hours to convert our
intentions
into very concrete and operational
decisions
and the result is a far-reaching joint
statement
and we are happy to announce excellent
news
on our trade disputes i'm certain ursula
will say
more about that today we focused
on four key areas of cooperation kavit
climate change trade investment
technology and
democracy peace and security first
we want to send kobit 19 to the history
books
and there is only one way the
international cooperation
and we must deliver on this by making
sure
that the world's population has access
to vaccine
we can do this in four key
ways first through the exports
second through kovacs third via
donations
and finally via the manufacturing
capacity
and our goal is clear we want to
vaccinate at least two-thirds
of the world's population by the end of
2022
the joint eu-us curvet manufacturing and
supply chain task force
will help achieve this goal by boosting
global vaccine production and keeping
supply chains
open learning the lessons from curvit 19
also means learning how to prepare for
future pandemics and health crisis
and we discuss a possible treaty on the
future pandemics
global recovery must mean recovery for
all and not just
select flu for a solid flu few we also
have a duty
and an interest to assist and to support
less developed countries not only to
fight kobe 19 but also
to recover economically
climatic
thank you mr president madam president
thank you very much
indeed we had an excellent meeting
got my first phone call by president
biden in february
and there we jointly decided to solve
this problem
and today i really want to thank our
negotiating team
the u.s trade representative catherine
terry and the executive vice president
valdis dombrovskis
they have been instrumental in
facilitating a solution
today we can say we have delivered
in general on trade the bilateral trade
and
investment between the european union
and the united states of america
is unrivaled despite the pandemic
trade between the european union and the
u.s was worth
almost 1 trillion euro in 2020
and to preserve this we discussed that
we need
to adapt to an even more competitive
and more diversified global environment
and therefore we decided to establish a
eu
us trade and technology council
we want of course to expand eu us trade
and investments
but we also want to discuss how we avoid
new unjustified technical barriers
and how to cooperate in areas with high
potential
from our economy especially of course in
the digital technologies
and the trade and technology council
will be a forum to cooperate
and align on global tech matters so
whether it's
artificial intelligence to set our
standards
and promote a human-centric artificial
intelligence
albeit the risks of cyber security
or be it in the environmental
field for example clean technologies
for in this forum of trade and
technology we will at the beginning of
course
focus on areas that are the most urgent
for example in semiconductors you know
that these are a key component in many
industries with significant supply
constraints and here it's really
worthwhile
to work together and to improve the
situation or we will work on platforms
and artificial intelligence areas
of ever increasing importance to our
economies and our societies
and as i've mentioned the cyber security
a threat we both
face and the threat that requires a
common response
the second topic i want to mention in
this overall
trade context is indeed the discussion
we had
on fair international corporate taxation
and we really commend the
leadership of leadership of president
biden
that he has shown with this proposal of
the first and the second pillar
we jointly aim to build on the recent
agreement at g7 finance ministers level
and we fully stand behind the oecd
process
so we have discussed of course the first
and the second pillar
but how does that go with our digital
levy
and here we made clear and discussed
that our proposal will be
non-discriminatory it will not lead
to double taxation once the pillar one
of the oecd agreement is in place
on 232 the steel and aluminium topic
we have decided to establish a working
group
to make sure that we find a solution as
soon as possible
we've discussed it broadly and i think
there will be good work and progress
with the aim
to to move forward in this difficult uh
difficult field within months
on the topic of health we've been
discussing how to end
of course the pandemic everywhere and
for everyone
this is a joint priority this is a joint
responsibility
we agree that we have to move faster and
quicker
to help vaccinate the world to get there
and you know all the issues we had in
the past six months to get there
we decided to establish a eu us vaccines
task force
to really work on the details if there
are bottlenecks in the supply chains and
other issues it will help to identify
and solve
problems that are connected to the
production of the vaccines
or also a production of therapeutics
and we agreed that it is necessary to
cooperate
much more to build capacity
worldwide in regions where there is no
production capacity right now
but where we need over time the
possibility to manufacture
vaccines there was clarity that for that
it is necessary not only to bring
private investment and de-risk this
price private investment
into these regions but also the question
of how to transfer technology know-how
to these regions so the whole discussion
around the trips agreement
and finally that we jointly commit to
maintain
supply chains open and maintain supply
chains
secure because these ingredients are
necessary if you want over time to
establish
new manufacturing capacities and really
create these new ecosystems
in regions where they haven't been so
far
another major step forward is that
we will now work together
more closely on the big questions on how
to reform who
we know that for the world health
organization a renewed engagement is
necessary
we know that who needs stronger
capacities for the detection of
outbreaks for example
of covet 19 the early notification the
early warning system
to really speak of preparedness and
appropriate response
and here the investigative power of who
must be increased
we've learned our lessons from the past
we know that we lost
time at the beginning of the pandemic
and this should not happen
anymore on climate change
the european union and the us are
natural partner
in the fight for our planet's future
and science tells us very clearly that
we have to hurry up
we need to do more and we need to do it
quickly
so i'm very pleased that we are
establishing today
a eu us higher level climate action
group the main focus is
really to work together on the momentum
that has been
created by the earth summit and really
work
on the climate diplomacy so that we have
many many countries going with us
towards the cop 26 in glasgow and really
forging
uh the ambitious goals we want to
achieve at cop26
we were briefly discussing that we also
need a robust global framework for
sustainable investment and reforms
we saw on both sides that there is a lot
of private capital out there
that looks is looking for true green
investment not green washing but true
green investment
and to work on such a global framework
that defines it as we've done and
started it with our taxonomy here in the
european union
this is a common goal because we know
that the
private sector can play a decisive and
will play a decisive role
in our fight against climate change
embedded in this is the fact that if we
want to fight climate change if we want
to be successful
then we need innovation and technologies
and
for that i welcome that we have
committed
to work towards a transatlantic green
technology
alliance so to make sure that on both
sides we are aware of the
latest development we can discuss how we
enable breakthrough technologies or
amazing innovations to be competitive at
the market
and to work on their uh on their their
market entrance
because we will rapidly need these new
technologies if we want to fight climate
change
last but not least we were discussing
uh the global pricing on co2 that it is
necessary
overall to have over time a global price
on
co2 be it through the uh emission
trading system
or be it through taxation and in this
context
i explained the logic of our carbon
border adjustment mechanism
and we discussed that we will exchange
on it
and that wto might facilitate this
i've been briefly touching the reform
necessity
in wto and here we also know that
there is a huge need to improve
an environmental agenda within wto
so this was the overall scope of this
discussion
thanks so much thank you madam president
we have a lot of journalists joining us
virtually but
i'll take a few questions first here in
the room since
this is new again having journalists
physically present um please
i'm from that day thank you anna galinek
city of german television
a question for the president of the
european commission
you've been talking about the return to
excellent trade relations between the eu
and the u.s so why was it not possible
to
also get rid of the taxes on aluminium
and steel what is the problem
here and on your discussions with
president
biden how much pressure did you feel
uh from the u.s side to side with them
on the topic of china
and um and and try to
talk harder and tougher on china than
the european union does it
well if i take perhaps the second
question first
uh china has been a big topic at g7
so there extensively we have been
discussing it and
we are very clearly aligned that the
european union says yes there are
ways where we cooperate with china for
example on the common goal to fight
climate change
we are strong economic competitors
without any questions and for that we
need
tools we need tools for the security
within the
digital market for example the 5g
toolbox but also foreign direct
investment
investment screening so that it is very
clear that we have the necessary tools
to
uh ensure that there is a level playing
field and that we otherwise if this is
not the case can protect our markets
and of course the fact that
if it comes to the system itself it
comes to human rights and human dignity
we are systemic rivals without any
question
and it was very clear in g7 that we have
to
speak up on that that we have to call on
that and be very clear
that this is the main issue that
clearly divides us um what your
the first part of your question is
concerned uh
first of all it was good to hear that
the us clearly
agrees with us that the european union
is not a national security threat
so uh we we we are happy about that
secondly we agreed that we both want
indeed to preserve a vibrant steel and
aluminium
industry this is important and we need
to work together to address
the serious global over capacity
problems we face
especially from non-market economies we
are all aware of that
within that we have now created a space
to find a solution
by suspending the eu counter measures
for six months
so this gives us room to sit down to
discuss more detailed
uh to find a solution that preserves our
industry
and that restores our historical trade
flows
and we are aware and our american
friends are also aware that we need to
do this before the suspension of our
counter measures expire
thank you um lotte you're next
thank you lotta mile from tv to denmark
for both
presidents what is the eu message
on russia for for biden to take along
to his meeting with putin tomorrow thank
you
the the first the first message is very
simple
we are united the 27 member states we
had
an in-depth debate a few weeks ago about
russia and we condemn
the illegal activities the disruptive
activities
of russia point one point two we want to
implement the five guiding principles
especially we think it's important to
play a strong role
uh at the level of the eastern
partnership but also in the western
balkans in order to support
robust democratic institutions in those
countries and indeed i think that with
united states with
some other like-minded partners it's
important not only to react
when we face authoritarian regimes
trying to put pressure on us
it's important to have a proactive
strategy in order to promote
our values and to defend our interests
yes indeed russia is europe's biggest
neighbor
and we have uh we are very clearly
united in our approach
to our uh biggest neighbor we must say
that the eu-russia
relationship is currently more on the
negative spiral
and you're all aware of the development
of the last years
um we would like to turn that
into if i may say some more predictable
relationship and we are very clear that
there are
three ways to approach that here too
clear push back on breaches of
international law
clear pushback on breaches of human
rights
secondly to constrain russia's attempts
to undermine us and thirdly to engage
there where it's possible
for example on a matter of public health
or if it's a question of people to keep
people contacts
but as i said uh currently the eu russia
relationship
is on a negative spiral and this is also
what we conveyed very clearly
to president biden i have a
question coming from angela morrow
who's joining us for the huffington post
virtually angela
uh yes i want to go back to
the steel and aluminium tariffs which
are
also an heritage of the trump era
like to know in in what terms did you
discuss this
meeting and what have you decided
because it it is not clear from the
previous question
at least to me thanks
yeah so um on
on the steel and aluminium indeed it is
something that is
coming from the area of the former
president
um here uh it is important our teams
have been working now over the weekend
day and night
mainly to solve the aircraft issue and
they were successful in that
and um they have agreed that as you know
the european union could have been able
to take counter measures right before
this summit
we were entitled to that and we
by purpose said no we will not do that
we will just suspend our counter
measures that we are entitled to take
for six months so beginning of december
and with that spirit
we've said let's sit down let's sort out
uh together within this time period
how we can get rid of this nuisance
and this issue but we need a little bit
of time because it's
more complex than to solve it within a
weekend and the first priority was
on the aircraft dispute so i'm confident
that we will find a solution
we also were very clear that the topic
of over capacity is not a
question of european steel and aluminium
because our export to the united states
dropped so it's another topic
and therefore i think we are good talks
uh to proceed
and as soon as possible get rid of this
problem
i have another question um
[Music]
question
[Music]
foreign
yes what the grisella what your question
of the aircraft dispute is concerned of
the normal dispute of
the aircraft topic there
i i think i mentioned that we have
installed a
working group um that is
detailing out and discussing on the
case-by-case level
uh whether the level playing field is
kept
or whether there are state aid issues so
it's a very practical approach
that has been chosen and you see there
was a strong will
really to solve that issue what your
second question is concerned if i got it
right
you were asking about the overall
financial
support here i think two
figures are interesting we have been
looking at
what is the fiscal support of the
european union on the european level
of course the member states level and
what we call the automatic
stabilizers in the european union for
the years 20 21 and 22
this will sum up around about to 18
percent of our gdp
and if you compare that with the same
levels in the
uh united states and the plans
that have been launched
by president biden or announced by
president biden
and you some sum it up over the three
years you come to a result of
20 percent of gdp so that shows
that we're pretty much aligned uh in our
policies
and that we share the same approach
that right now we should not
pull out prematurely pull out of the
supportive measures we should not repeat
the mistakes of the last
big financial crisis but we should
maintain
the fiscal support also through 22
knowing that policies then have to be
more differentiated so to prepare
for the years to come where the fiscal
support will be reduced
i'll take one more question from the
room beda
please
yes good afternoon veda romanus i had a
question to mrs van der lion
um you met mr biden uh
for a number of days from friday onwards
um did you have the possibility of
explaining to him
the concept of european sovereignty
of strategic autonomy
and did he ask you more information
about these two concepts
and what kind of reaction did he have to
your explanation thank you very much
so we did not touch on this specific
term but it was impressive to see
and to listen to president biden how
clearly he
first of all was acknowledging that
yes we know that the last four years
were difficult
and the world has changed but europe has
also changed
but there's a second important point we
are long-standing friends and allies and
we share
many many same world views and we share
the same values
and the third point which was for me
impressive i don't know how it was for
you but
the way he explained to the two of us uh
how much he cares about europe because
as he said we need we
americans need europe and the same goes
for us
we europeans need our american friends
because these are the democracies
who uphold the values and to stand up
for the fundamental rights um and the
values we
really cherish and respect
and this atmosphere shows there is
the knowledge that we are different of
course
but we are one if you look at
fighting for
thank you mr president and madam
president thanks and this concludes our
press conference for today see you
again next week for our european council
you